There is nothing nothing you can do to stop this
now Welcome back everyone this will be my video
for stranger things season four episode eight and
episode nine there were a whole bunch of easter
eggs and references and then setting up what's
going on during season five what's going on with
vecna so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos i'll be doing episodes for season
five and i'll be doing a season five video right
after this too careful for spoilers from all of
season four if you haven't seen the episodes yet
we'll just start at the beginning and work
our way through episode by episode talking
about easter eggs and wtf moments starting with
episode 8 it was titled papa that's a reference
to brenner who all the kids in the program call
papa even vecna calls papa still thinks of him
as papa and it's all about brenner's role in
shaping everything that's happening with vecna
trying to absorb the main dimension completely
reshape everything to his whim within becoming
the ruler of the main dimension using the mind
flare i'll explain that plot too like he explains
everything over the past couple seasons in what
was going on with all the different villains
in how it is he's able to use this hive mind his
advantage controlling everything and how he's
going to do that to the main dimension soon really
it's going to wind up being like the combined two
dimensions like it'll be one giant dimension with
everything kind of merging into one all this stuff
on the show is really happening because of what
brenner did to all them even though vecna blames
eleven like you're the one that helped me become
who i am today really brenner is to blame for
all this because he's the one that did all the
experiments and pushed all the kids abused them
for all those years but in present day brenner
even tries to continue manipulating 11 forcing
her to do what he wants even though he's trying
to save the main dimension like he does care about
her in his really messed up kind of way he tries
to save her from the military but it's one of
those situations where like he's killing everyone
with his kindness like i love you but i'm doing
really really terrible things to you in the show
really want you to believe that he dies during
episode 8 in the desert and i do think that he's
actually dead this time even though they really
want you to believe he was dead in earlier seasons
like this time it's going to stick i think this is
mostly because this is season four they're heading
into the final season like season five is gonna be
it for the show so they have to kill off a couple
characters a couple of the big characters to at
least make it feel like there's some stakes on the
show they're really only a couple of the bigger
characters that die eddie i think is probably the
biggest character just because of the way they set
him up but brenner being the other big one so rip
to the two of them the episode starts with vegna
showing nancy a vision of the future telling her
all his plans everything about what's going on
with the four separate kills the four separate
micro gates opening the master gate everything
that comes to pass at the end of episode nine like
here's a preview of everything that's happening in
the finale so if it wasn't clear the central focal
point for his new super gate like the master gate
whatever you want to call it is in the center of
town because he said it's all going to start in
hawkins i'm going to burn that to the ground and
then it's going to happen to the rest of the world
the rest of the main dimension and i'm going to
reshape everything to my whim they confirm that
max is meant to be like the last kill that he
needs to open the last little minor gate so that
the master gate could open the way they explained
the twist with her during the finale is that she
died for like a minute but then she came back
like 11 brought her consciousness back so she's
just in a coma right now but because during that
episode when they were fighting each other she
did die for a minute that was enough to weaken
that final minor gate to open the master gate
so that's why the master gate was able to open of
all the stuff that happens during these final two
episodes and they are like super long episodes
particularly the finale the only part that's
really important is the stuff that's happening
in hawkins and the stuff that's happening with
eleven's group in california all the stuff with
hopper and russia isn't really critical for the
plot like that's all kind of extra stuff none
of what they're doing has any real huge effect
on what's going on with their fight with vecna
or anything like that but everyone comes back
to hawkins in the finale so like everyone will
be critical to the plot in the final season did
you use some of the russia scenes to set up some
of the big twists that you learn about from vecna
in the finale like the whole thing with the black
sentient swirly cloud that is essentially the mind
flayer they show you a version of that in russia
that they were experimenting on and containment
but it's in the finale that vetna explains what
the mind flayer was and how he's using it as
sort of another finger puppet to create his hive
mind situation and control all the other things
inside the upside down and eventually his plan
is to do the same thing in the main dimension
don't worry i'll explain that in a second too like
he explains how the mind flayer is critical to his
control like the hive mind in the way that he
controls everything else later in the episode
but if it wasn't clear they confirmed that there
never was any actual mind flayer villain creature
like it was a sentient black cloud that just lived
inside the upside down but along came vecna and
used his power to mind control it and then through
it vicariously control everything else so like
yes it does exist but it wasn't like really the
villain during season two it was vecna this whole
time during season one season two season three
controlling all these different villains seemingly
trying to get back into the main dimension so like
he's the one who sent the demogorgon after them in
season one vecna sent the demo dog since season
two and all the other creatures in season three
all vecna controlling them all using those
particles from the black sentient cloud that
was kind of the mind flayer they kind of clarify
how he uses the mindflayer particles to control
other things and reanimate their bodies we also
finally find out what was going on with will's
mystery painting it's not quite as big of a twist
as i was expecting it's just a depiction of their
group of friends the dnd group with eleven
fighting the vecna but done in the style of
a classic dungeons and dragons art piece like
they're all knights fighting a big red dragon
but the red dragon is just a metaphor for vecna
will also says that eleven asked him specifically
to draw this particular picture he doesn't come
out to mike discreetly or anything like that
or even his brother like he kind of tells them
subtly so he kind of came out during the episode
but i think part of the idea is that he's meant
to have feelings for mike and those just do not
come to fruition like he understands that mike is
with eleven like oh no this is never gonna happen
and when they steal the rv eddie uses a michael
myers halloween mask to disguise himself the
first halloween movie came out in 1978 so they
would have already seen a couple of the sequels
already because the episode takes place during
1986. in real life that michael myers mask
during the halloween series was just a real-life
william shatner mask that john carpenter turned
into the michael myers mask so technically michael
myers has been running around in all those movies
with william shatner's face this whole time moving
into episode 9 episode 9 is titled the piggyback
it's a reference to 11 following max into the mind
space into her memory so that she can fight vecna
she literally tells max that she piggybacked to
her from a pizza dough freezer it's also meant
to be a reference to vecna piggybacking into the
main dimension using eleven's power like he tried
to get her to do all these different things in
all these seasons to get himself back into the
main dimension and help open a big enough gate
to combine both dimensions so that he can just
control everything using the mindflayer's power
although what's really happening here just to be
clear it's more about both dimensions the upside
down dimension the main dimension combining into
a single one with everything ultimately just
turning into a version of the upside down which
vecna would be capable of controlling because of
his hive mind connection to everything like he can
also physically control it as well so that's
why he says he wants to reshape the world but
the reason why this part of the upside down looks
just like hawkins especially during season one is
because of what happened with the mother gate when
eleven opened the big one during season one it was
like a small version of what you see happening
in the finale so when she opened the mother gate
that caused both dimensions to overlap at this
particular point so you just see like a little
bit of hawkins existing in the upside down like
it looks like a copy of the real world because the
dimensions are literally overlapping at this point
the idea in the finale is the master gate will
open up far enough that the dimensions will fully
overlap and like everything will combine into one
it seems like the only things though that don't
combine into one or like the actual living humans
like all the buildings the grass the tree
everything looks like the upside down or starts to
look like the upside down in hawkins but all the
people aren't gonna like turn into demogorgons or
anything like that like there'll still be people
walking around the whole reason why elevens group
uses the pizza dough freezer to help try and save
max is just because they don't have time to make
it back to hawkins in time to save max like we
need a shortcut all right we'll do this with the
mayan space if you remember earlier during episode
8 brenner said that 11 would have to learn to fly
before she could defeat vecna i don't know if he
actually meant that they'll literally make her fly
on the show like that would be pretty cool if she
does that in real life but when she's inside this
mind space kind of like vegna they can literally
break the laws of physics it works more like the
matrix like matrix rule she can fly teleport do
anything she can imagine herself doing because
it's all happening in their minds that's also why
there's three different versions of vecna's house
creel house there's the physical versions the
one in the regular dimension like the real house
there's one in the upside down that's a copy that
the red version is the one inside the mind space
during the russia storyline murray makes an empire
strikes back star wars reference when he says
i don't know jim i've got a bad feeling about
this because the episode is taking place in 1986
they would have all seen empire strikes back that
came out in 1981 season one takes place in 1983
for reference and because the actors are aging up
so fast they said that their plan between season
four and season five was to have a much bigger
time jump so i think when season five picks up
you just see way more of hawkins being turned into
the upside down they have a bunch of jokes about
pineapple on pizza that's a war that's gonna rage
for the rest of time the vast majority the rest
of the episode here and it's a very long episode
is really just about 11 finding max saving her
and then defeating vegna we get a little bit more
information from max's storyline like she talks
a little bit about what's been happening with her
but it was all information that i think that most
everybody understood already like everybody
kind of understood what her trauma was there
already been a lot of clues for that she says
that she felt guilty for wanting billy to die
wanting to get away from him even though she was
experiencing all this abuse and she wanted to get
as far away from it as possible and because of
that she felt like she deserved all the terrible
things that were happening to her during season
four invecna was just able to take advantage of
that and use her as one of his targets eddie winds
up dedicating his cover song of metallica's master
of puppets to chrissy so that they can distract
the demo batson up for the upside down steve crew
to kill vecna's physical body they also have a
joke in the episode where they yell about how
eddie doesn't have any good music when they're
trying to save nancy eddie yells at them saying
that all his heavy metal tapes are real music like
this is good music this is all music you notice
like the last part of the episode before 11 starts
fighting vecna full on she winds up in a version
of the snowball which is basically like the season
2 finale and while this is all going on like while
they're busy fighting vegna there's this whole
side plot with the basketball team and jason
coming for them at creel house and even though
jason is killed by the master gate like r.i.p
he's literally cut in half when the gate opens
that was actually pretty cool kill at the end of
the episode when the news is broadcasting about
what the real world thinks is actually happening
here the police still blame all the dez on the
hellfire club in eddie they don't know anything
that's happening with vecna or with the upside
down or what's going on with the master gate they
just think that it's some natural disaster so like
that's going to continue into season five like
they'll be fugitives they'll still be after some
of those kids that are part of the hellfire club
but then we have our long vecna villain monologue
where he explains the rest of his backstory and
everything that happened to him after he came to
his senses in the upside down dimension like after
eleven had pushed him in there originally he said
he basically surveyed the area and then eventually
found the mind flare creature the black particles
and learned that it had a psychic connection
through those black particles to all the other
living creatures in the upside down and just
used it to vicariously control everything living
in the upside down so if it wasn't clear before
vecna came along the demogorgons all those
creatures even the black sentient cloud that
is the mind flare were already living creatures
inside the upside down he came along used his
power to control the mind flayer and vicariously
then use it to control everything else in when
eleven closed the mother gate during season two
his sidestep plan was then to open the master gate
with the four weaker gates which we see happen
during the course of season four killing those
four people so that he can open the much larger
gate and when he tells 11 that she was the person
who did this to him made all this possible
he's just saying that he as number one henry
would have never realized this level of power his
plan would have never come to fruition had she not
pushed him into the upside down dimension remember
none of this would work if he didn't have the
power of the mind flayer at his disposal like he'd
be able to control other things with his power but
not in the same way like the mind flayer black
particles are key to him scaling his power up to
this large white area of effect but max is still
alive she'll be back in season five the only big
characters who really died were brenner eddie and
jason if you consider jason to be a big character
vegna's body disappearing is also their way of
saying that he's still alive and will return in
season 5. like will even says later in the episode
i can still feel his presence everywhere now but
like the whole last 30 minutes of the episode is
like a lord of the rings return of the king style
epilogue with like an ending after the ending
where you see all the repercussions of the master
gate opening and what happens to all the regular
people what the world is thinking about all this
like i said nobody really knows what's going on
they just think this is this weird supernatural
natural disaster kind of problem they're blaming
on the hellfire club the california group makes it
back hopper's group makes it back from russia so
like everybody is back in hawkins for season five
you also notice at the hospital lucas is reading
stephen king to max while she's in the coma
the book is the talisman the plot of that story
is meant to be similar in commentary on what's
happening during stranger things like that story
is a multiverse kind of story and a lot of things
that happened during that are similar to things
that happened during the stranger things season
4 season 5 story robin seems like she's going to
wind up going out with vicki during season 5 or
maybe in season 5 after they defeat vecna dustin
winds up telling eddie's uncle about what happened
to him and sort of memorializing him like no no he
died a hero they explained that 11 and hopper are
moving back into their shack because she still
needs to hide out like it's the same shack from
earlier in season two there's even an eggo box
that's still left over don't eat any of those
and the way that will explains it is that they're
treating what happened during their final battle
in season four is a loss like eleven thinks
that she lost to vecna and i think the idea
with brenner saying that she needed to be more
powerful you need to learn to fly is the whole
idea like that she had this inner power to open
the portals to other dimensions and she'll just
get more powerful heading into season five and
eventually be able to close the master gate
but like this moment after all the reunions
where they all look up at the sky and it starts
looking more like the upside down it's just meant
to be more of a season five teaser like an end
credits kind of tag scene where the upside down
starts merging more fully with the main dimension
so the idea is they're gonna be a really big
time jump when season five picks up more of
hawkins will look just like the upside down like
it'll continue to look worse and worse and worse
but what'll happen is i'll do a dedicated season
5 video after this that should post pretty soon so
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss that but if you have any big
questions about plot points or anything that
happened during the episodes that i didn't address
during the video just write those below in the
comments and i'll try to answer them then while
you wait for everything click here for my brand
new marvel ant-man 3 avengers footage breakdown
and easter egg from avengers quantum encounter
and click here for my full boys season 3 episode
7 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!